what is the best method to grow my
business if i had to pick one word i
would choose partnerships when you can
partner up with companies who already
have your target market and they can
introduce you to their clients it saves
you the work of having to go and find
all these individual clients one by one
by one and wasting your time on the
wrong people you're talking the people
who can make instant introductions to
you already have your target market and
it's the fastest way to grow a new or
existing business i got a great question
that came in from one of my research
moses who's just started in the
insurance business he's 18 months in
he's all alone he doesn't have any
employees he wants to grow this thing up
and right now everything he's done is
through cold calling and he wrote in
with that question what is the best
method to grow my business up and what
kind of advice can you give me so cold
calling can work i don't want to knock
cold calling i've never been a huge fan
of it myself
but it's one of the hardest ways i've
found to grow a business
because
you have to get a list
and the list
you know may not be all that great then
you have to call people you're
interrupting their day when they're not
expecting a call from you you're hoping
that they're actually there
at their desk to be able to talk to you
and more and more people aren't picking
up their phones and away from the office
and you may be giving them value but
they're not
prepared to talk to you they may not be
going through that challenge that you're
able to help solve for them
whereas if you're able to talk to
partners if you're able to talk to
people who understand your target market
who are dealing with them day in and day
out they're servicing them
and if they know that their customers
have a problem
and you can help solve it
you're not selling anymore
you're being helpful you're being a
friend you're doing a good service
so if you're selling insurance say
you're selling to to entrepreneurs
the best people you want to talk to are
other people who are talking to
entrepreneurs and selling to them so who
would
entrepreneurs buy from before they buy
from you
this is your thought process you want to
look at in the chain before somebody
makes a decision to buy your product if
it's insurance
who are the people that they're buying
from before they come to you
so if i'm looking at entrepreneurs maybe
i'm buying some legal services i'm
talking to a lawyer maybe i'm buying
accounting services and talking to an
accountant
go talk to those guys
make relationships let them know what
you do let them know you focus in on
entrepreneurs and you really care about
business owners
and when they're talking to their
clients
and they find out that they have an
insurance need
you want them to pass your name along
okay it's not just calling these guys up
and saying hey i'm an insurance broker
uh can we have some kind of partnership
you need to actually go out and form
relationships you have to get them to
know you like you trust you and actually
want to pass business onto you these are
their trusted clients
but if you can do that
then you only need to maintain
relationships with a few key people in a
few key industries and they'll keep
passing you a flood of new business
and you're doing them a service
some people may want a commission
but most people do it because
they're adding value to their customers
lives right that lawyer who understands
that their
their customer has a problem with
insurance and you can help solve it for
them if that lawyer passes them on to
you you do a great job that makes the
lawyer look good
the fastest way to grow that business
is through partnerships so again i use
an example here with entrepreneurship
pick one that fits your market
find the people who are already selling
to your customers and find a way to work
together
you can always try the other methods if
cold calls working for you keep going
but from my experience
the best way the way with the most
success will come through partnerships
believe
for those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me want to do more for you and
please leave a comment under this video
every morning i wake up and i check my
youtube video comments and it's the
highlight of my day it's the way i get
started so please leave a comment below
i'll give you a personal response i
might do a video response for you too
thank you so much and i'll see you soon